in this section we are going to
take the sample gadget
that we just created
that gave gifts to our friends
and modify it a little bit
so that we can see the gifts,
after we have given them
we are going to start
by modifying our give gift function
so that instead of just updating data
it also requests data back
in our data request object we are
going to specify that in
addition to updating the views
application data
we also request
information on the viewer
the viewer friends and the personal
information storage of the viewer
in the load friends function,
we're also going to
do something similar
so that when we load our list of
friends and our view friends
we also request the personal
application storage of the viewer
we are going to make these two
requests parallel each other
so that when we initialize the
gadget or give a gift
we can send the callback
the same set of information
then we modify our "onLoad"
friends function
so that in addition to specifying
the viewer and the viewer friends
we pull out the gift data which is
the list of gifts that we've given
again, we create the list of
friends as a selection menu
and once that has been
inserted into the page
we call the update gift list
function
which will display the list
of gifts we have given.
update gift list pulls information
out of the data array
that we have given it
specified by the view id
and the key of gifts
which is where our information
is stored
we then take this data and
convert it back from a "json string"
into a javascript object we can use
once we have this object,
which is a pairing of a friend id
and a gift id
we can convert that into a string
which specifies
the friend that we have given the
gift to
and the gift we have given them
we can then insert this list
into the page as html
Finally we make a small change to
the gadget XML file
so that we have somewhere
to insert the html
here's a new version of our gadget
that now displays
the list of gifts that we have given
so that when I click on the give
gift button,
it shows up in the
list below.
for more information on
what i just showed you
and more information on the
social API
please check out the tutorial on
"code.google.com"
under the open social section